leave us alone when the time comes he
must be trained
like you trained his father oh
silver
stings
you still want all right tommy uh pause
right here look at this look at this
look at this okay so
this is
terrifying to me the creepiest detail of
this trailer the red shelf that is like
perfectly lit
like someone's like creepy basement
where they have all these old war
collectibles yes there's a bunch of
lightsabers each one different but one
of the domed helmets that the younglings
wear to blind them when they're training
in the temple
this is what they're keeping as trophies
stuff taken from kids
[Music]
yes that's so messed up yeah this is i
feel like it's very concerning very
concerning the way i pause this i feel
like one of those tick tockers who has
the uh the incredibles music that damn
yeah and
they're like
that's a detail that eric vos debunked
two months ago but i'm gonna get a bunch
of tick tock followers from this yeah
is that von doom cupcakes no it's von
darrell make cupcakes but i'm gonna
pretend it's von doom and i'm gonna put
a little a screen grab of me like
putting it into google and then the
drop-down search history shows up with
me searching for it yes hey tick tock's
a great platform and everyone on it
is doing great work stop ripping us off
or we're sending the lawyers after you
what lawyers there's no lawyers no
lawyer reviewed my contract when i
started working from here was written on
the back of a napkin of a chuck e cheese
ah the fact that you have a contract is
amazing i all i have is uh an adult an
adult comes and picks me up every day at
10 am and takes me to work
my contract expired um the year
chernobyl leaked so
youtube didn't even exist yet
they just guessed they're like they'll
be a thing don't worry we have a good we
have a good feeling they'll be pretty
good guessing though the forest side of
that contract you know the lawyer wrote
that contract the one lawyer involved in
all of this had some was very prescient
uh yeah well he was warning us about all
kinds of things in september 2001 and uh
november 2016. and
he told us he told us to uh we start
wearing masks right around uh 2020 so
that was weird yeah
yeah it was weird yeah i blame him for
all but i do
well welcome back to d rock stars
a new trailer for obi-wan kenobi takes
us deeper into the hunt for any jedi
survivors of order 66 but does that
purge include trophies that darth
vader's inquisitors keep of the jedi
they have killed even the young ladies
oh my god this is wikileaks it's our
weekly reaction to the latest in star
wars i'm here with tommy bechtold tommy
this is something i wasn't here with you
guys last week when you first reacted to
this trailer i'm sorry i would have
loved to but i love watching you guys
every day because
we appreciate that we loved having you
even for a brief moment on our first
episode but uh yeah i i will say well i
i i'm very surprised because there was
all the uh
fuss about oh kenobi's rated nine plus
for disney like it's going to be like a
really childish show and i'm like no
this seems very very dark
yeah they're hunting children down uh no
spoilers for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness that's a big
conversation about around that movie is
it it's pretty insanely violent i think
it is completely safe pg-13 especially
when you look at the history of pg-13
movies i love the clip that's going
around of jurassic world of when bryce
dallas howard's assistant gets brutally
mauled by at least three different
dinosaurs and that scored a pg one of
the most horrific things i've seen yeah
in the pg-13 movie for sure um but uh
yeah i think kids can uh handle way more
violence i agree i agree they have to
see it on the news every day
yeah the reality is always going to be
more terrifying than uh anything that uh
dave filoni can cook up yeah or was
already there in revenge of the city
yeah fair point
christian's flesh burn as he screamed i
hate you i mean that's pretty funny
to me fair every time my parents took me
to a beach as a child when my flesh was
burning i shouted that at them so well
for me i quoted a ruth and ozark you're
gonna have to
kill me
[Applause]
to get me to the beach my skin that
would kill me to put me in direct
sunlight like i mean i'm sure eventually
it is gonna catch up to me so you know
indirectly my parents did murder me at
that age but
that's indirectly all of our parents
murdered us by bringing us into this
world that's true and you know what's on
a inevitable fate i'm gonna sick our
lawyer on that merrick you just reminded
us
our fortune teller lawyer
yes
all right well this week on wikileaks
we're going to react to this new trailer
for obi-wan kenobi on disney plus uh the
super creepy detail that we spotted and
talk about obi-wan's mugshot what other
jedi could be uh hunted down just talk
about what it means what it's gonna look
like the hunt for the jedi on this
season of obi-wan kenobi we see season
because we're holding hold on to hope
that we'll get a season two give us more
living on a prayer give us more you did
that with moon night you're like this is
a limited series and then it's like no
that's right forgot to bring this uh
that's kidding
we got toys we want to sell that's right
there's merch to sell baby
speaking of our merch partners at epic
hero shop have a new latest obsession
shirt inspired by doctor strange the
multiverse of man is called shattered
madness but here on wikileaks we got a
special design coming at the end of the
month for obi-wan kenobi keep an eye out
for that because when you get that one
tommy and i are going to be discussing
all your shoutouts calling you out uh
making fun of you uh telling you hey you
came up with an idea we never could have
thought of so be sure to get that shirt
all right let's talk about uh this whole
question oh eric i think if there was
ever a time for the framing of a
question
to include this phrase i'm gonna say
what the fet
will the hunt for the jedi look like
yeah uh i think it's i think that's
gonna be a bigger part of the kenobi
series that a lot of us think a lot of
us think that this is just an excuse to
pump out six episodes to get more
subscribers to see ewan and hayden
christensen fight each other again as uh
obi-wan kenobi and darth vader and
that's it but no no no i really do think
that the inquisitors and the way they
purge the jedi whichever ones have
survived order 66 is going to be the big
part at least for the first couple
episodes of the series uh and we see a
little new glimpse of that in this
latest trailer this shot on the fortress
inquisitorius showing the fifth brother
and reva the third sister and a new
character looks like the seventh sister
that hasn't been confirmed yet that's
just where i'm theorizing right now uh
as well as in dear varma's imperial
officer character overlooking a map and
uh when i looked at the orabish on this
trailer uh the planet there is mapuzo
which is just a really deep cut from the
star wars role-playing game in the 90s
uh i just i think they're just pulling
it's really fun how in star wars they
never just pull it's rare that they
create a new planet i guess we're
getting daiyou on this series which is
completely new to star wars but a lot of
the times they'll just put in like
whenever they have to pull a random
planet name they'll pull one from the
rolodex yeah and it will have some weird
history already to it so i just love
that they did that
but the scarier detail here is that
perfectly lit red shelf the rest of this
room horrible lighting this shelf is
beautifully lit gorgeous uh showing a
row of lightsabers and this domed helmet
that looks like the view blocking
helmets worn by the jedi younglings in
the jedi temple now lightsabers being
kept as trophies we completely get i
mean general grievous loved his dangly
ones but
these helmets
helmets it's like this would be like the
nazis keeping as trophies training
wheels that they tear off kids bikes
it's just so messed up it's so messed up
that you would keep a trophy something
that would only fit the head of a child
what what is this it's so messed up uh
but i think it gives us an insight into
how merciless
and thorough
cruelly thorough these inquisitors are
and i i think that's gonna be a huge
selling point uh you know a huge
detail the the main thing we're gonna be
talking about from these earlier
episodes is just what exactly this purge
meant for people right it wasn't just a
quick montage no no this is something
that people had to live with for decades
being hunted down like this and we
talked about the other jedi survivors
who survived order 66 whose mugshots
might appear alongside obi-wan's mug
shot which we saw in this episode there
was uh we got to translate some auravest
there interestingly uh he was wanted for
high treason that seems to be just the
general thing all jedi are uh accused of
because they're all part of that
conspiratorial plot to overthrow the
emperor right right um but we have uh
the other jedi who are out there ahsoka
tano luminaro and dooley caleb doom
calcus uh a number of others um now a
quick question i want to ask you do you
think abel nanjiani is playing another
one of these escaped jedi i really hope
so i just based on that quick like the
way he's dressed and the way he looks in
that i i i theorized on break room
either he's playing a jedi or he's
playing
uh a a fan of the jedi is kind of
similar to the way we had uh the guy in
uh rogue or rogue one for forgive me for
getting the character's name who was
like a jedi fan like loved the
philosophy of the jedi but wasn't an
actual jedi oh was he a fan though i
don't know if i would call him a fan are
you talking about donnie yen's character
yeah
chirrut emway he was like uh he was
probably more religious than your
average jedi was that guy was like a
guardian of the will he was like yeah he
was super in the in yeah neck deep in
that for sure
but i know what you mean yeah he could
be another one of these rather than
having gone through the jedi dogma and
uh gotten his degree in any good job
it was homeschooled homeschooled on the
subject yeah uh i like that idea i think
um i i ultimately think you know just
camille dan gianni's just playing that
anxiety and that fear just in that one
shot like i don't know of anyone else in
this world right now who would be so
afraid
yeah a jedi right and i think a lot of
people just don't picture camilla he's
more of a a comedic uh right but he's so
ripped now from eternals he still is
like you can play anything yeah the guy
can do anything and uh i think this is a
different world of jedi this is like you
know 10 years or so later than the purge
i think this guy is uh maybe someone who
would have been a kid at the time oh
yeah or just like a very young man who
was still
you know might have had a bit of his
personality still in intact when this
purge began it's just been kind of
living on the streets ever since i would
have been amazed that this guy could
have survived this long you know how
hard it's been for all the other jedi
they really really had to completely go
off the grid and completely change their
names so i i would love to hear his
story he's also a pretty big star yes i
mean even at the time this was cast he
was already booked on eternals he was
already a pretty big name he had been in
the big sick so i don't know how you get
command on gianni in the show unless you
give him pretty juicy roll that doesn't
mean it's necessarily a jedi i'm just
saying it's going to be a pretty big
role i i i agree i i'm pulling for jedi
eric i'm going to i'm going to go ahead
and place my bets that he's he's going
to end up being a a hiding jedi yeah i
think so too but on obi-wan's mug shot
it reads bounty upon capture which i
thought really interesting uh was really
interesting because the empire doesn't
necessarily want him dead or alive we've
seen the the phrase dead or alive on
other star wars mugshots before so that
term does exist in the star wars
universe um they say bounty upon capture
which means like you got to capture them
bring to us and then we'll pay you and
we'll decide what to do with them now
that could also mean he could be frozen
in carbonite that's kind of a way a lot
of bounty hunters get around it of
course right um but
why do you think the empire wants
obi-wan alive
we've seen in the movies and in tv that
the empire really values a good
old-fashioned torture interrogation and
like they're like there's things in this
guy's mind that he's either been taught
or experienced that we can use to
capture more jedis and find the rest of
the jedi so uh i think that they're
having him alive and also it's a little
personal right like vader probably wants
to be the one that if someone's gonna
kill kenobi spoiler alert does work out
for him uh
long long in the future like vader
probably wants it to be hit yeah uh i
think for sure it is personal between
vader uh and obi-wan absolutely i and i
think there's kind of a creepy
uh
you know sub agenda to this of using
obi-wan kenobi to learn the other jedi
as you said yeah uh there was that
detail from rebels where we heard him
make that broadcast kind of warning the
other jedi um i don't know if he would
have no he would have made that at this
point in the timeline because that was
like shortly after order 66 i think yeah
i've never seen him make that in live
action uh i would love to see like you
know the way that uh ahsoka was a
fulcrum agent during this time releasing
these broadcasts to the scattered
members of the of the
rebellion like it'd be fun to see other
kind of uh
transmissions that obi-wan might have
made and that maybe he's been doing this
all this time and that is why the empire
wants him is they want to use him as
like a propaganda instrument you know
maybe compel him to say other things
that say i've surrendered jedi i've
changed my ways i'm a convert maybe yeah
or like yeah like using him as a beacon
to call people in and say like it's okay
don't worry come on in it's fine guys
water's warm yeah head on down to the
empire water's warm
you know what's interesting is like when
we catch up to the inquisitors and
rebels
uh the grand inquisitor is using the
corpse of luminara unduly as that kind
of beacon yeah like her
signature can still be used in a would
like so they develop this skill i don't
know if that skill has always been there
that's something they might learn on
this series
oh actually we've developed this way
that we can
harness the the midichlorians that exist
still around the jedi's corpse and use
that to uh to lure in other jedi to use
that kind of uh that illusion um i don't
know if that's something they have yet i
may be wrong about this but
it would seem like if they wanted to use
obi-wan as that kind of beacon that they
wouldn't they could use his corpse to do
that if they had that technology unless
they don't have it yet which is also
very interesting that that may be a
reason why they keep all their
lightsabers in their helmet is they're
trying the way that like darth moment is
attached to a mask and that's how what
when sidious gave it to vader uh and
that mask was instrumental with vader
building his castle on mustafar um
like maybe that's something that the
inquisitors are working on to try to use
this for jedi but use it in a way to uh
to hunt down the other jedi um which is
a really really dark yeah dark thick i'm
sure this is okay for we're gonna we're
gonna be covering these episodes and be
like
oh god it's like it's like episode five
of moon night we're all gonna just be
like uh first of all if anyone just
needs to talk about it reach out and uh
yeah you know you know my thingy tommy
is that
all these shows need to start exposing
kids to like uh real grown-up subjects
sooner because the real world is going
to be thrusting that upon them right and
i i don't believe i think when you try
to overly sensitize kids and keep them
preciously pure
from the real-life horrors of the world
they're just gonna hit a rude awakening
when they're eventually released into
that world prepare them prepare these
children also it's a tv show it's media
it's fine it's okay i think there's
something arguably more problematic
about watching animated anakin skywalker
and clone wars commit a war crime by
doing a false surrender to the
separatists just to bombard them when
they're when they finally drop their
arms that's messed up yeah that's almost
as messed up as some of the you know
the the violence the just the body
horror that you see on some of these
things yeah um teach kids like what war
crimes are yeah if you're gonna also
freak them out over over blood
um
because they're gonna get a bloody nose
at school and you don't want them to
faint yeah and you know some war crimes
at school too for sure if it's anything
like my school experience there'll be a
few rules of engagement gone wrong
there's a couple false surrenders that
happened on the dodgeball court
no no no no no i'm already out i'm
already out i'm already out psyched
we'll decide whether you're out
i'm the one who throws uh
i don't know
walter white uh
yes but i agree eric um these kids gotta
know these kids got to learn they got it
up so uh i mean i don't have a son so
who or a daughter who am i to say
what
talk to me in a few years when i have a
kid i'm gonna be like don't you talk to
my precious baby yes
what do i know we only let eric jr watch
backyardigans and even that we censor
i'm going to be like this daniel tiger
is a little too intense for her
there's that one episode where he sells
molly uh no that's not true i made that
up
dino tiger's giving himself a squeeze
nice and slow just a little too hard
a little too hard come on daniel meow
meow meow meow
meow meow all right um we have another
thing we want to talk about from this
obi-wan kenobi trailer but uh i want to
quickly give a shout out to the break
room because new rockstar is now
broadcasting live every day from our
very own break room down in southern
california you can tune in every weekday
afternoon to catch tommy as well as
jessica clement
off-screen producer zach off-screen
producer brandon you guys are doing
special stuff on that show and i i'm
very much enjoying it i wish i could be
there i it makes me bummed that i'm not
living down in southern california
anymore because i miss all you guys i've
always been i would love to be part of
that show but i think you guys are doing
great and i love it and it's so funny to
see all the bits you guys come up with
we're having on so i want you guys all
of you watch it if you are not uh it's
every weekday uh around like 3 p.m
pacific time 6 p.m east coast time so um
they're going to be covering all the
latest news um they're going to be
reacting to the breakdowns i do pointing
out when i'm full of crap
but most importantly they're gonna be
interacting with all of you in the chat
you can send in your crazy thoughts and
theories and they'll be uh they'll be
responding which is really fun we'll not
smile and then we'll alert the
authorities we'll say like yeah
it's a really great point and of course
we're pushing the page if you miss it
when it airs live
uh there's no panic button that panic
button does not work it was installed in
the 80s it's just one of those staples
that was easy buttons you hit it it just
goes wow that was easy but it says it in
kind of a sensual term
like
that was easy oh that was easy
your fingers why is it wet yeah why are
your fingers sticky oh my god
it was oh god
um anyway don't miss the break room
aaron today there's gonna be an episode
here today on your rock stars yes yes
yes so finish if it may be on right now
as you're watching this video please
finish watching this video and then go
over listen do me a favor and finish
this one for the old
team money and then check out the next
one don't stop watching now um
and then see if tommy acts differently
with me than he does with the other
three is he holding himself back with me
is he is he censoring himself with me i
want to hear about it
i don't think i can't go any further
take me away
well tommy from this obi-wan kenobi
trailer and all this footage we still
have not yet seen kenobi use his
lightsaber he only uses an uncivilized
blaster obviously he doesn't want to
identify himself as a jedi he doesn't
use the weapon of a jedi but i wanted to
ask you what incident what do you think
will finally be the thing that causes
obi-wan to finally ignite his lightsaber
on this series so i think that the
obvious uh uh answer would be a
one-on-one showdown with vader but i
actually think it might that might be a
misdirection
i could see
there being a uh
unseen undetected threat towards luke
that that luke has no awareness of as a
kid that obi-wan has to very quickly
like take his lightsaber out and
dispatch of someone yeah and like
to save luke's life again luke
completely unaware obviously i know luke
doesn't like you know
have any sort of like
uh understanding that obi-wan is a jedi
until he's much older but i could see i
think it's not gonna ever i'm sure we're
all thinking like oh as soon as he meets
up with vader he's just gonna pull out
his lightsaber and go like all right
let's do this but i think i think it
might actually be something more
um
uh technical like he's just he needs to
use his lightsaber a blast it won't
suffice to save
luke or maybe even another young jedi or
young force sensitive kid that can't
help themselves yeah i think that's a
really good thought tommy of like using
it to protect someone uh i mean we know
from the comics that i'm pretty sure
obi-wan would use his lightsaber to like
fight off a great dragon they're in the
tattooing stand yeah oh for sure he
fought when he fights uh bk black santa
um that might be taking place during the
series or like shortly after maybe
shortly before i don't know if we'll see
black chrysanthes show up i think that'd
be really fun
um but yeah i think on this series
you're right it's gonna be something to
protect someone in some kind of life or
death circumstance i'm wondering do we
think he might kill or engage
an inquisitor like the inquisitors are
such a threat and the only way you can
defeat an inquisitor is by me and
meeting them lightsaber blade with
lightsaber yeah it's not like he can use
a blaster it's gonna be really hard for
him to take down an inquisitor yeah uh
and there might be some other inquisitor
who we have not yet seen some someone
that obi-wan has to just like
quickly take out his lightsaber to
engage and that's kind of what alerts
them like one of our inquisitors died
that hasn't happened in a few years yeah
that sounds great to me i would love
that that would be amazing i mean it
seems like
when you know rev is going to attract
arrival is going to track him down to
die you um she has her lightsaber out in
the trailer she's screaming after him
right i have a feeling that these two
are going to engage in some kind of
sword combat on daiyu
i don't i don't want reva to die on this
series she seems like moses ingram is
great i kind of want her to have a long
history in the in the star wars canon
yeah sure until she has her end
eventually all inquisitors are gonna
kick the bucket probably right but that
would yeah seemingly yes yeah um but
yeah i i think it's gonna be a huge
moment when he finally does like this it
sounds like something that you know star
wars wouldn't uh or this series might
not show us until like the end of
episode two or something like that like
they're gonna delay it because it's
gonna be such like a big moment when he
finally does yeah for sure um and it's
gonna be such an important
part of his character journey right now
he's hiding himself he's even changed
his name a little bit just a little bit
though this time um but
just tidying him out and not the most
important
he's kept he's kept the most identical
or identifiable part of the name
i think what he does it's gonna be a
pretty symbolic moment for the character
to finally reveal himself once i think
it's gonna be awesome i can't wait to
see him i can't wait we're not far we're
so close we're so close 18 days uh away
uh and it's gonna be the first two
episodes during star wars celebration i
don't know how we're gonna handle that
week but
it's gonna be a blast yes we'll leave it
there for this episode of wikileaks
don't forget to check out our many great
merch options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me at ea boss
follow tommy at tommybacktoe follow new
rockstars subscribe to wikileaks
wherever you get your podcasts thank you
for watching we have spoken
[Music]
you